[THEME MUSIC]
[SAMANTHA BARKS SINGING "THIS IS
MY LIFE"]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
ANDY KARL: Next.
[LAUGHTER]
I love that song, by the way--
"This Is My Life," if you
couldn't tell by the title.
[ANDY KARL SINGING "FREEDOM"]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: That was fantastic.
Please, have a seat.
And I'd love to also invite
up Paula Wagner, the show's
producer.
Where's Paula?
Excellent.
[APPLAUSE]
So that was fantastic.
It brought back--
just this weekend,
I saw the show, which
was equally amazing.
And I thought, maybe
to kick us off,
what we could do, just by way
of introduction to this crowd,
is that each of you could
just share a tiny bit
about your background
and, really,
what attracted you to want
to be part of this project.
PAULA WAGNER: Well, sitting
next to these two people,
how could I not?
SPEAKER: I get that.
PAULA WAGNER: I actually got
involved earlier than they did.
But I'd known
Garry Marshall, who
was the real spirit
and inspiration.
And who doesn't love this movie?
It is really one of the
great movies of all times.
It's more watched and
re-watched all over the world
than almost any film.
Everywhere in the
world, they know it.
So it was exciting.
And of course, working
with Samantha and Andy
is just a dream--
really a dream--
and our whole cast.
And to be able to work with
Bryan Adams and Jim Vallance
and Jerry Mitchell, JF Lawton--
our entire cast--
Orfeh, who's fantastic.
SPEAKER: What a team.
PAULA WAGNER: Eric Anderson--
I could just go on and on.
I have done just
about everything
you can do in this business.
I started as an actress.
I was one of those
summer stock kids.
I've done everything.
I've hung lights.
I've done props.
I've done it all.
And I was an agent in Hollywood.
And I had a production company.
I've produced many, many
movies, a lot of action films.
And it was time to--
ANDY KARL: There's a little one
we should know about, right?
It's just a little
independent film--
"Mission Impossible"
films, I believe.
PAULA WAGNER: Yeah.
The first three.
"Mission I, II"--
ANDY KARL: Just the first three.
PAULA WAGNER: The
origin story, really.
But there's something magical
about musicals on Broadway.
And it's my favorite thing.
And I love every minute of it.
And everything I've ever
done has organically
led to the next thing.
SPEAKER: Well, we're
grateful it led to this.
Andy?
PAULA WAGNER: Thank you.
ANDY KARL: Oh, yeah.
Becoming involved with
"Pretty Woman," my story,
it basically starts at Broadway.
I wasn't involved in the
out-of-town runs with Chicago
and doing the workshops,
but I had seen them all,
because my wife, Orfeh,
who was mentioned before,
plays Kit De Luca in the show.
So I was a fan of
the show already,
and certainly a fan of Samantha.
I was like, star right here.
It's pretty amazing.
And I was like,
oh, this is great.
Honey, have a great
time doing the show.
I'll see you later.
And then the role of Edward
Lewis opened up for Broadway.
And Jerry Mitchell, who I knew
from doing "Legally Blonde,"
called me up.
And he's like, would
you like to do it?
And I was like, what?
Are you kidding?
I wasn't sure.
I had to think about
it for a second.
Because I was like,
[STUTTERING] I'm not sure--
should I be doing this?
Is this the right role?
But then I realized,
my wife's doing it.
I know Jerry Mitchell very well.
I know the show very
well from seeing it.
Samantha's a star.
This is amazing.
And Garry Marshall and
I had worked together,
where I played the
Fonz in "Happy Days--
The Musical" at the Falcon
Theater, in his theater,
many years ago.
And so I was friends
already with the family.
I was, basically,
friends with everybody
that was already
part of the show.
And then, a few hours later,
I sang through the music
just to see if I could.
Because it's Bryan Adams,
and all respect to him--
he's amazing and can write
incredible pop tunes,
but also has a voice that
no man can actually sing.
SAMANTHA BARKS:
Higher than mine.
ANDY KARL: It's
higher than yours.
So I was, like, I don't
think I can sing that high.
But they lowered
the keys for me.
No.
Eight shows a week,
singing these tunes,
you know, it's got
to be in the pocket.
And then the role just sort of--
I examined it.
And Edward Lewis, in
the film, does a lot--
Richard Gere does a lot of
this-- like takes to the camera
like.
So I'm like, what's
behind all that?
Where's all the internal
monologue stuff?
Who is this character?
And then you realize
how complex he is.
And we talked about
the dialogue and maybe
adding a few lines here
that really hone in
on this character.
And the songs open up a whole
thing for the character.
And then I was fully in.
I was like, oh, wait.
I have to do Edward Lewis.
This is great.
PAULA WAGNER: We
had to have him.
ANDY KARL: Thank you.
PAULA WAGNER: From the
beginning-- from the beginning.
But you were doing another show.
ANDY KARL: I'm glad
I was in the mix.
PAULA WAGNER: More than
in-- you were-- you were it.
ANDY KARL: It was just great.
It was great to come on board.
And we've just been
having a blast since.
And that's been my journey
with "Pretty Woman."
SPEAKER: And I feel like you
do see a few of those looks
in the show, just like that.
ANDY KARL: Yeah--
[LAUGHING]
--I would have paid for.
SAMANTHA BARKS:
Smolder-- the smolder.
ANDY KARL: Yeah, I gave
you a few smolders.
SPEAKER: Yes, that's the word.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Well, yeah.
I'm not even from here.
I'm from England.
And so, yeah.
Yeah, did you-- did you?
ANDY KARL: Didn't know.
SAMANTHA BARKS: No clue.
OK.
And honestly, for
me, the moment--
I was flicking through,
and I saw "Pretty Woman--
The Musical."
And the moment I saw
that, I was like, well,
I'm desperate to do that role.
There wasn't even
a question mark.
It was just like, that role--
what a gift of a role.
And I saw Jerry was
directing it, who
I'd always wanted to work with.
And I'd seen all of his shows
and been such a fan of his.
So honestly, for me, the
minute I got the music--
it said "Bryan Adams."
Because I'd just received
all the information,
and I hadn't even
read anything before.
I was like, let
me see the music.
Let me see.
And I was like, Bryan Adams.
That's a weird name
for a songwriter
if it's not Bryan Adams.
I was like, hang on.
You can't be called Bryan
Adams and be a songwriter.
And I was like, not Bryan Adams.
He was like, yes.
Did you not read the email?
I was like, I was so excited.
So yeah.
So all the elements--
it was just a no-brainer.
I was just like, get me
into that room to audition.
PAULA WAGNER: Samantha
was a no-brainer for us,
I can tell you.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Well, honestly,
it's just been amazing.
And it's been really, for me--
I was thinking around
my last birthday
was when I first
started with the show.
It was this time last
year when we did the lab,
and we started to workshop.
And then I went out of town
with it, in Chicago, and now
to Broadway.
And this is my Broadway debut.
And it's just been magic.
I can't believe
that I get to do it.
I can't believe it.
And we have so much fun.
And that, for us, was--
the minute we met-- and
we met just socially.
I went to see him
in "Groundhog Day,"
and then he came
to see the show.
And it is like an
amazing family.
And just all the elements.
Paula is absolutely a hero.
We just are so, so
lucky to have her.
And it's an amazing
group of people.
And that makes it all
just even more special.
SPEAKER: I mean,
that's incredible.
And what a transition
from London to New York.
SAMANTHA BARKS: A bit of a jump.
SPEAKER: Well, and with that,
I guess I'm curious, right,
because you've got this
iconic story with all
of the legends
that surround that.
Then, you've got this
incredible dream team
surrounding the entire
show, and sitting here.
And I guess, just starting
with you a little bit,
what was it like to
bring that to life?
Were you anxious
about expectations?
Were you just beyond
with all the talent?
How did you experience it?
SAMANTHA BARKS: I think,
with a project like this,
it's so loved to start--
this movie is so loved.
These characters
are so well loved.
And Julia Roberts is so loved.
And Richard Gere-- it's magic.
They're all magic.
And so I feel like, I guess,
for me, starting it, I just,
I don't feel that you can
walk in carrying all that
and being scared of
all that, and fearful.
I was just excited
about the challenge
of getting to get stuck in
and get to know this character
and translate this
character for a musical.
We get to sing songs
by Bryan Adams.
That, already,
means that you get
to create something different.
And it's been really
fascinating trying
to work these characters
into a musical world
and see how they communicate.
PAULA WAGNER: Garry Marshall,
from actually the moment
that the film came out, saw
this as a musical for Broadway.
That was his dream.
And we're very happy
that his dream came true.
But he worked on it
until he passed away.
We did the first act--
actually, Orfeh was with us.
We worked on the first act.
And then he passed away.
But we carried on.
And it was his dream.
He always felt the
musicality of the show.
SPEAKER: That's amazing.
PAULA WAGNER: And
with these people.
SPEAKER: Well, it's
an incredible vision.
And I was saying
to them backstage
that I wasn't sure
what to expect,
having loved the movie so much.
A take on that is
always a challenge.
But the freshness and
retaining everything
that was important
about the film, but also
bringing a fresh take with
all of this creativity,
was really incredible.
And I'm curious--
and maybe, Paula,
this is a question for you--
the film came out in 1990.
This is opening in 2018.
How did you think
about making it fresh
and yet keeping the heart?
Was there a strategy?
Did it just happen?
PAULA WAGNER: It
took a long time.
And I have to credit
my creative team--
Jerry Mitchell, JF
Lawton, who wrote
the original, original
script, obviously
Garry Marshall's
spirit and vision,
it infuses every moment.
And Bryan Adams, of course, who
brought this incredible sound
and passion and depth.
And it was the right
thing at the right time--
Bryan Adams and Jim Vallance.
Jim is a very gifted songwriter,
and the two people together.
And we work with our musicians--
Will Van Dyke, whom you
saw up here, who's amazing.
We just have this great team.
And what it is, is
how do you translate--
as Andy said-- how do you
translate a look to stage?
How do you translate
passion to stage?
And it's the musicality
of those moments.
And when you have a
superb cast, as we do,
and they bring to life the inner
workings of that character--
and particularly in the
character Vivian and Edward--
you stay true to the movie
that everybody knows and loves
and all those great moments.
But you also bring something
that has a contemporary feel.
Our young woman is
more independent.
She knows how to handle
herself, but she's
searching for something.
But she doesn't take any kind
of inappropriate behavior
from anybody else,
and that's different.
She maybe has made a mistake
with what she's doing.
But she's going to
figure it all out.
And that's her journey.
And in the process,
she saves him.
SPEAKER: How much were
you watching the movie
over and over and studying it?
How much of it was trying to
just independently put yourself
in today's version of
that character, the way
Paula's describing?
What was your process?
ANDY KARL: It was
interesting because I
did go back and watch the film
when I was being considered.
And I wanted to see,
what is the core?
Where's all the stuff land?
And it lands in the
chemistry between the two
lead characters.
Richard Gere and Julia Roberts
have this incredible chemistry.
And you're just sucked in.
And you want to go
along for the ride.
Julia Roberts is just amazing.
And so when I saw Samantha do
it, I was like, she's got it.
You're sucked in.
I'm totally with her story.
Samantha's handling this
character amazingly.
I was like, when I
join, I want there
to be this immediate friendship,
interesting, romantic thing
that needs to start weaving
from the very get-go of the show
and end up with the
audience just wanting them
to be together so
badly that there's
such joy in it at the end,
which I think we found.
I feel like we have, because
they're all applauding
at the end when we kiss--
and when she rescues him
right back is just incredible.
And I feel like we win that way.
That was my main objective
is just to make sure
that the two of us, onstage,
find what the element is
in saving each other and
becoming the evolved characters
at the end.
She finds strength.
Edward finds he can let
go of all of his chambers
around his heart, let go
of his father passing away.
There's all this stuff that we
don't hone in on in the show.
It's not a depressing
piece about my father
dying or anything.
But it's about being able
to love even when you think
you're at the top of your game.
It's when you have
all this stuff,
and you're looking
around, and you've got
the silver spoon in your mouth.
You've been given everything,
every opportunity in the world.
And what are you missing?
Really, it's just the
heart and the compassion.
That was my journey and
making sure that that worked.
SPEAKER: I love that.
And Samantha, would
you add anything?
SAMANTHA BARKS:
Do you know what?
For me, I did not
watch the movie.
So the minute I first found out
that I was going to audition,
I didn't watch the movie, and I
haven't watched it since before
then.
I don't know when
the last time it was.
I watched it, probably, not
long before that because who
hasn't watched "Pretty
Woman" at least once a year
every year of their life?
But no, I haven't watched it.
Because it's hard
because they're
such iconic performances.
And we have so many elements
of the movie in our show, which
we want to make
sure that we deliver
that nostalgia, for sure, but
also telling our own version
of these characters.
So yeah, I don't know.
Because for me, it would
be hard to re-watch it now.
Because I'm doing my own thing--
still, absolutely, with respect
to the amazing performance
that Julia Roberts gave,
which is just so
iconic, but also
trying to do my own version.
So for me, I haven't watched it.
I don't dare to watch it.
SPEAKER: I totally get that.
Well, and I heard that
Julia Roberts actually
came and watched you.
So how was that?
SAMANTHA BARKS: Oh, yes.
Well, I didn't know
she was watching.
So it was a tribute
night to Garry Marshall,
and it was amazing--
what an amazing night.
And then at the end,
there was a speech,
and it was, hi to Julia
Roberts in the audience.
I was like, what do you
mean Julia Roberts is
in the audience?
She came backstage, and
I was like, oh, wow.
And she just hugged me.
And we just stayed hugging.
And I was like, this
is just so amazing.
SPEAKER: That's amazing.
SAMANTHA BARKS:
And it was just--
it was so special
to have her in.
And she was so lovely and
encouraging and supportive
of what we were
doing, and of me,
which just made my heart burst.
It was really a dream.
And she's so beautiful.
I don't even mean just to
look at-- because she's
stunning to look at-- but
she's got this amazing,
almost like this
light around her.
And she just-- her smile is--
oh, I could go on for days.
[LAUGHTER]
It was an amazing moment.
It really was.
SPEAKER: Oh, god,
I can only imagine.
I wanted to turn
back to you, Paula,
and say it's a hot topic
now, women in Hollywood,
et cetera, et cetera.
How, if at all, did you
feel like the leadership
of this show--
did you experience it any
differently as a woman?
Did you think being
a woman brought
a different touch or not?
PAULA WAGNER: Well, I have--
how do I say it?--
been in a leadership position
for a long time in my career.
And so I have
looked at it as what
are the skills of leadership
and really working
toward the qualities that
a good leader should have,
which is compassion
and understanding.
And I guess I've done
about every job you
can do in the theater
and film and television.
So it's understanding
what everybody
is doing and being
collaborative, and working
with the very best people and
supporting them and encouraging
them to do their very best work.
And we have this
great group of people.
And then, of course,
there's Jerry Mitchell,
who is so phenomenal and so
exceptional as a director
and brought his energy
and passion and desire.
And the director, really,
is the creative leader.
They're the ones that take
and put everything together.
And so what I watch on stage
is a beautiful collaboration.
So it makes being the lead
producer easy and fun.
SPEAKER: That's the
best part of a job.
Well, and one other thing that's
an interesting commonality
is there's actually a lot of
married couples at Google.
I don't know if that's
a little-known fact.
But I'm just curious, you're
in the show with your wife,
and you've worked
with her before.
How does that translate
in a theater environment?
How does that work for you guys?
ANDY KARL: We worked together
on a couple of different shows.
One was the Jerry Mitchell show.
We did "Legally
Blonde" together,
where she played Paulette,
and I was Kyle, the UPS guy.
We wound up being
onstage together.
That was our first
Broadway turn.
Oh, no.
It was our second.
We had done "Saturday Night
Fever" before that, years ago.
And we've since done concerts
together and other productions.
So this is our
third Broadway show.
And actually, just based
on scheduling alone,
that's the dream, if
you can work together.
Now we can both walk the dogs at
the same time and/or feed them.
We can schedule our
lives, as opposed to,
I'm coming in for six hours,
you're going out for six hours.
I have to fly off here,
you're flying off there.
So right now, it's a
little wonderful thing,
being together just
outside of the show.
Inside of the show, we actually
never see each other onstage--
ever, except for the bows.
Because she's just on her
own journey of her character,
and I'm on mine.
I just have such respect
for my wife's talent,
and I've always had it.
I saw her onstage before
I actually met her, once.
I was like, oh, my god.
Chick's amazing.
And then, I got to meet her
and be in a show with her.
And we were dating
six weeks later.
And I was like, I took
advantage of a situation.
So 18 years later, we're
still doing what we do.
And we're different
performers, and we're
different people, and full
respect for that, as well.
So if we were, I
guess, too identical,
I don't know if maybe we might
rub each other the wrong way.
I'm not sure.
But I just let her do her
thing, which is amazing.
If you see the show, you're
not going to miss her.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Oh, if you
haven't heard Orfeh's voice,
it's like--
if I heard that, I would
be like, marry me, please.
Honestly, a voice that you've
never heard anything like it.
It's like, OK.
PAULA WAGNER: She's fantastic.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Huge voice.
And she's just-- oh,
my, gosh, amazing.
Wow.
I love her character, too.
ANDY KARL: I think that's
it-- just respect and also
good scheduling.
SPEAKER: Practical and romantic.
I like it.
PAULA WAGNER: We have a
great "Pretty Woman" family.
SAMANTHA BARKS:
Yeah, I can see that.
All right, let's go to the mics.
AUDIENCE: Question for Andy.
So I loved seeing you--
I'm a fan of yours--
I loved seeing you
in "Legally Blonde,"
"Rocky," "Groundhog Day."
I haven't seen this yet.
The question is, is
there a particular reason
you do so many shows
that are based on movies?
ANDY KARL: They just
come around, man.
There's a lot of them
that come into town.
It was really interesting
because my first show
that I ever did that was
like that was "Saturday Night
Fever," where I met my wife.
And I went on as Tony Manero
because almost every matinee,
I was going on as the lead.
And it was my first going into a
show that was based on a movie,
based on a character,
and kind of
went for, (WITH ACCENT)
would you watch the hair?
You know.
I work on the hair a long time.
And I was sort of mimicking
the style and the dance
and nostalgia pieces putting in.
So I've kind of been
skilled at it now.
It's finding the right
amount of nostalgia
in order to bring
the audience in
to know what they're watching,
and then bring as much honesty
to the character as possible.
I think there's something
in doing that many that I've
found the spot.
It all depends,
also, on the show.
"Groundhog Day," I thought,
found its own world--
bananas, spinning stage,
world of trying to--
it was trying to find
its own idea of a show.
And it was terrific and
such a incredible journey
of a character.
And we ran for six months.
So we closed.
And I was like, man.
PAULA WAGNER: But you won
the Olivier Award in London--
ANDY KARL: There's that.
PAULA WAGNER: --I have to say,
and was nominated for a Tony.
ANDY KARL: So it's about
where's the line of nostalgia
and then also bringing
something joyous.
It's catching the
right amount of what
the movie was, but
then also bringing
a joy you've never seen before.
I think "Pretty Woman"
balances that line so well.
And the audiences
are just coming in
and going nuts for it.
But basically, there's
just so many people
who want to make-- it's these
good pieces that people want
to make into
musicals-- because you
want to hear these people sing.
I think "Pretty Woman"
was one of those things
like, that would
make a great musical.
"Legally Blonde,"
it was like, that
would make a great-- you think
about it and how would it be?
And then you find
people like me,
who are stupid enough to do it.
PAULA WAGNER: We're the
recipient of his genius.
ANDY KARL: But it's
definitely a fun skill
to know where the line lies
and tiptoe around it and show
the audience, come on.
I'm about to say the line.
You know what's
going to come here.
But I'm giving you
something else.
Because you want to search
for what makes it special.
SPEAKER: By the
way, when you talk
about the audience coming
in and being crazy for it,
who are they?
Are the early-goers
nostalgic Gen Xers?
Are they kids who are excited?
Is it everybody?
PAULA WAGNER: Everybody.
People from all over the world--
young people, people who were
young when the movie was on,
who now are nostalgic.
But really interesting
young people--
18, people 13 plus, I would say.
It really is that
amazing array--
women, men, couples.
They leave the theater
kind of embracing.
A group of women
together-- they'll come
sometimes dressed
in red dresses.
There's something about it.
I talked to a
group of women that
had all come from Illinois,
the heartland of Illinois.
They come to the
theater once a year
and have a women's reunion.
And this is the show they came
to, and they just loved it.
SPEAKER: I just got chills.
OK, I think we have
another question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
Thanks for coming.
When I think of
Broadway shows, there
are a lot of names that
come along with that.
Bryan Adams, until recently,
was not one of them.
Paula, maybe you could
talk to who had the idea
to get Bryan involved?
How did that happen?
How did he write the music?
PAULA WAGNER: Great ideas come
from many different places.
Both of these
phenomenal actors--
there were so many
different people who said,
they have to do this.
They have to do this.
And Bryan had seen the show--
knew the movie years ago.
And he himself had wanted
to do this for a long time,
as did Jerry Mitchell want
to do this for a long time.
But somehow, he knew
someone who knew someone,
and somebody called me
and said, Bryan Adams.
And it was like a
light bulb went off.
It was kind of like,
yeah, Bryan Adams.
You've got it.
That sounds great.
Jerry was like, absolutely.
Our whole team--
Garry Marshall, JF Lawton--
everybody was like,
we have to do this.
And Bryan and Jim
Vallance came in.
They wrote two songs.
I think both or one of
them are still in the show.
They were so good.
They did it quickly,
and it was like, yes.
How could it be anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you
SPEAKER: Very cool.
All right.
I'm going to give the
audience one more chance
to ask questions.
But in the meantime, one
question I have for each of you
is, hopefully, this is going to
be-- and I'm sure it will be--
a long and amazing run.
But the show also talks a lot
about dreams and the importance
of always having a dream
of where you're going
and what are you doing.
Beyond this project, what's the
dream project for each of you?
SAMANTHA BARKS: Well, this is
like a dream project for me.
Truly, I've always wanted to
originate a Broadway show.
That's always been a
huge dream of mine.
And I started doing musicals--
did "Les Mis-- The
Musical, and that's
what brought me into film.
Did the "Les Mis"
film, and then I
was doing movies, pretty
much, for the next few years.
But always, in the
back of my mind,
I just thought, I really want
to do a proper run of a show
and really get in early
and create the character
and have that creative process.
And truly, this
has been a dream.
This was the big
one that I really
wanted to get to try and do.
And I've loved it.
And so I don't know
about the future.
I've never been very
sure about the future.
SPEAKER: How do you think about
the difference between theater
and film?
Does that affect
anything in terms of how
you think about the future?
SAMANTHA BARKS: Well,
I do love them both.
But they're such
different disciplines.
They really are.
And the pros and cons
are equal for both,
because there's so many pros.
But I'd say that film
is like a sprint,
and theater is like a marathon.
And so with theater, it's
definitely different,
and it's about sustaining
high energy for a long period
of time-- eight shows a week--
SPEAKER: Yeah, it's amazing.
SAMANTHA BARKS: --whereas
a film can almost
feel like for two
or three months,
you don't speak to
anyone or see anyone.
And you're just in the
film, doing a film,
on location somewhere.
And it's almost like
three months of your life,
but then that's it.
So I don't know.
I love having the
opportunity to do both.
Yeah.
I feel very lucky that
I've got to do both.
And I'd love to continue
just interesting roles.
SPEAKER: I think we'll be
excited for whatever you do.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Andy?
ANDY KARL: Yeah,
interesting roles.
I had those dreams once
of being on Broadway,
and then it happened.
[LAUGHTER]
I was like, what's next?
Um, no.
It all just comes down
now to, luckily, I've
had some opportunities to be in
Broadway shows in great roles,
this included.
And so when something
comes around,
it's either like, that
sounds really great,
what are they going
to do with it?
Let me see.
Open the pages.
And then, if it looks
really like there's
a journey happening that
could be really fun,
or something that I
could bring to it,
man, that's the
next thing to do.
That, and be a Marvel superhero.
That's kind of where I'm--
PAULA WAGNER: You're
our superhero.
SPEAKER: That dream
never dies for boys, huh?
ANDY KARL: Yeah, it never does.
Never does.
Always returns.
PAULA WAGNER: You know, we're
in an era right now-- two things
interesting is that
live entertainment is
more popular than ever.
The theater, the Broadway
revenues and attendance--
the revenues are up
15% from last year.
SPEAKER: That's amazing.
PAULA WAGNER: And what's
fabulous, what's going on now,
is crossover.
So actors like Andy and
Samantha and Orfeh and Eric--
all of our fabulous actors--
can go from theater
to film to television.
And it's all OK.
It used to be much more
segmented where, as an actor,
you were either a film star
or you were a television star
or you did Broadway.
And you didn't really
cross over with fluidity.
But now, you can.
And I think both of these
two amazing talents,
you will see them
on film, television.
They'll do more Broadway.
There's a wonderful
opportunity now,
I think, for actors who have
their talent, who sing, dance,
act.
SPEAKER: I think
that's phenomenal.
Were there any
behind-the-scenes sneak
peeks you can give
us from this one,
in terms of anything funny
that happened on set,
or your absolute favorite scene?
You actually do look nervous
climbing that trellis.
Is there anything
we should know?
ANDY KARL: Oh, that's acting.
SPEAKER: Just genius acting.
OK.
ANDY KARL: (THROATY)
I'm that good.
Live theater is
wonderful because there's
little imperfections
almost every show.
There's always like,
oh, that's new.
Oh, let's try that.
Or we bring things to scenes.
We're like, oh, all right.
She's going in today.
Let's go.
You can adjust, which is part of
the fun of doing live theater.
But there's certainly-- I
think someone belched right
before we were about
to kiss at the most
romantic possible point.
And it was silent
in the audience.
And somebody was
like [FAKE BELCHING]..
And we both looked
at each other's eyes.
We're like, don't go.
Don't you laugh.
Let's just kiss.
And we're laughing into
each other's faces.
So that happens every
once in a while.
And that's part of the
process of live theater.
It's like, you either
totally avoid it or even give
a little beat, like
when she comes out in--
surprise-- the red
dress that's everywhere.
It's gorgeous, and
it's a gorgeous moment.
It's lit very well, and
the audience applauds.
And sometimes, they're
really like, they love it,
and they're in it, and they let
themselves go and just enjoy
the dress.
And so I just hold, and I'm
just like, yeah, watch, people.
Please.
Go.
And you make it live.
PAULA WAGNER: Well,
you have a line that--
don't you say, you look lovely?
I happened to be
in the audience,
and everything was dead silent.
And everybody was like, oh.
Some guy goes, yeah,
out in the audience.
[LAUGHTER]
Remember that?
SPEAKER: Oh, my gosh.
That's hilarious.
Well, listen, I think-- oh,
we have another question.
AUDIENCE: Drawing parallels
and lessons a little bit
to business and what we do
here at Google, Samantha,
you mentioned sustained high
energy and coming in day
in, day out, eight shows a week.
Has there been a
time when you come in
and you're like, oh, I don't
want to do this, I'm tired?
And how do you get over that?
So maybe little tips about--
SPEAKER: What parallel
are you referring to?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: We're doing
some crazy things here.
And then, maybe just a tip on
how you deal with stage fright,
if you have them.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Yeah.
Well, I think, when going into
a theater contract, for me,
I know that I need to
get into that mindset.
And so I'll start eating
healthily and going to the gym
and making sure
my stamina levels
are as high as they
can possibly be.
Because it doesn't stop.
It's eight shows a week.
It never stops.
And so, for me, I
find I have to make
a lot of lifestyle adjustments
when I'm going into a contract.
So in my spare time,
it's so relaxing.
And I don't really go
out particularly drinking
and things like that.
I don't do a lot of things to
try and give my body the best
break that I possibly can.
And so sometimes that
means that you might not
be able to go out for
drinks with your friends
and a birthday thing.
And hopefully, your
friends understand
that your schedule is so busy,
and you try to make it up
in other ways and not
going to silly things--
like not going to a bar that
has loud music because you
can't use your voice.
So it's things that you would
never really think about
until you go, how can
I give my body the best
break so that tomorrow my voice
is 100% or I have 100% energy?
But it's a process.
You learn.
You go, oh, that
didn't feel very good.
Or some people like
to go to the gym.
You like to go to the gym.
You work out before a show,
and that gives you energy.
It's a trial and error, I think.
SPEAKER: Well, listen.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I really wasn't sure
what I was going to think
when I went to see the show.
And I kind of knew I'd
have to say something
nice, no matter what, right?
Because, obviously.
But I honestly can say--
[LAUGHTER]
--no, really-- the
way you articulate it
is what I felt in the
audience, right-- that joy,
that love, that hope, that
uniqueness of the moment.
And so I just really
want to thank you
for putting it all
together and for what
you bring to the stage.
And I think it creates
an amazing moment that
will last for me, and I
know for all the other folks
who see it, too.
And if you're willing--
and I sense that you are--
we would love to have you
close us out with one more
live performance.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Yes.
PAULA WAGNER: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SAMANTHA BARKS AND ANDY KARL
SINGING "LONG WAY HOME"]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ANDY KARL: Thank
you all very much.
SAMANTHA BARKS: Yes.